APPROACH TO HELP CE SPREAD C TES
A .
WELL, ALL  SHORTLY OO THAT AREOY
EFFECT MONDAY AND WILL LAST S.TO
THUG
'LL VE
THIS IS POST OLYMPICS,
ABLE SITUATIONE YOU HA T OLYMPIS
UER , D FANS
>>or LYNDA, EXACTLY.
THESE GAMES E UNPRSO MANY YSCOVF
LY, DECISION
COEF TO MUCH UBLIC HERE AND FORN
SPECTATORS.
TOKYO IS DEALIH A SURGE IN
COVID- CHESUASN 900 ON
WEDNESDAHEST IDEIS
COBUTING TNEW
VID CASES HERETOKYO.
LEAD TOTSPIKE.AT THESE GAM C
ONIN PUSDI POTENTIALLY EVEN
. IS
TOERE TH OF THC EVENTS ARE
HELDE OTHER PREFRE
ARE HOSTING OLYMPIC EVENTS, WE D
AT THOSEPREVIO OSAID
UP T P
OVASNOWN MANY MONTHS NOW HAEEN
MED.
IT IA  LOCKDOWN, BUT
IT MEAHAS
ARE GOG TO HAVE  DOWN
AND HOL IS GOIO
AMID A STATE OF EMERGENCY EN
E R STREETS AND IN T
RLD'S T ORTING EVENT IS STILL GO
GO AHEAD
B OLYMPICICLY TIMCOUNS.S IN SY
OLYMPICS HAPPENED NORMALLY THE
FECI>> Reporter:THAT'SRESS ARE
RIGHT.
THE LOW CCE
NOW, THERE A WHOLE
MOST TALWHY JAPAN, ONEF
S BEEN
REASO I
SCANDA OF  HAS  V
T THL PROCES
IN ADDITIO THAT,
BES OF LOGISTICAL HURDLES.
RECENS THE S FINALLENPI
UPT AGAIN, MUNIP
CHALLENGES.C AOGISTICA
BUT E  BEE
PICKINIGQUIT'SNGRE THE
OLYMPICSRT
PROTESAS YOUAYEEENING HERE T
I I WAS
STERY ANGRY AND
ISTEOTESTER D
ME TODAY.
>> Translator: WOULYWITH
AND OVERSEAS VISITORS WILLNGS R
>> RorE HEAD OF
E  A DEEPLY UNINTHAT W THES
IOPUSHIND AT THE EXPENS P A
IT IS REALLY AN ECEDENTED
MES, LYNDA, IN SO MANYS.
AND THE PUBL